le printemps est là et pourtant la saint
maclou à mantes la jolie
les chalets de noël sont sortis tous les
samedis depuis le 27 mars des
restaurateurs profitent de ces
installations
prêté par la commune pour faire de la
vente à emporter on a encouragé ce
projet parce qu'on a eu des demandes des
restaurateurs qui nous proposons proposé
l'idée et on a trouvé que c'était une
excellente idée que de permettre aux
restaurateurs qui sont quand même 12
mois durement touché par la crise de
pouvoir reprendre contact avec leurs
clients en extérieur en respectant
évidemment les gestes de sanitaires des
restaurateurs différents sont présents
chaque semaine avec une carte légèrement
différente de ce qu'ils proposent
habituellement mais la qualité elle
reste de mise et les professionnels s'en
réjouisse c'est déjà un pas en avant qui
reprennent lé enthousiasme et de la
motivation est de l'espoir surtout de
réouvrir assez rapidement aujourd'hui en
plus on a un beau temps donc on espère
pouvoir au moins réouvrir bientôt les
terrasses puis à terme ré ouvrir
normalement et les clients répondent
présents et en demandent encore plus le
fait de voir le visuel
évidemment ça donne envie et puis ça m'a
l'air bien bon parce que dans les
restaurants les autres endroits c'est
difficile de trouver des capes et
d'épées cupcake jeu venu soutenir les
restaurateurs look afin d'augmenter
c'est très bien mais je trouve qu'ils ne
manquent de chalais ce serait bien
qu'ils aient un peu plus de
restaurateurs tout on connaît pas tout
le monde donc qu'on puisse faire
connaissance avec nos commerçants le
village de restaurateurs sera ouvert
tous les samedis de 11h à 14h pour le
salé et de 11h à 16h pour le sucré et ce
jusqu'à la réouverture des
établissements